what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and she-hulk episode 3
is now out many people have said it's
their favorite episode so far and it is
the first episode where we kind of get a
set up for the overall villain of the
show which hasn't really been revealed
yet i do believe that titania is going
to be one of the main villains of the
show however i do think there is a
bigger villain that is behind a lot of
things including the wrecking crew who
we did see attack jennifer walters in
this episode with as guardian
construction gear that they were using
as weapons which of course would have
worked on any normal person but jyn is
she-hulk now of course she-hulk tears
them apart she literally bashes their
heads together and they pretty quickly
realize that it was a bad idea as the
leader yells bad idea and they all run
away now these guys seem like some
pretty big amateurs and you can tell as
they get back to the van they say boss
is gonna be mad of course none of these
people are in charge they're just the
lackeys but i know that everybody is
dying to know who the boss is now i must
say that i have seen episodes one
through four and in episode four we do
not find out who the boss is so i do not
know who the boss actually is but of
course i have a theory and i think this
is how everything is going to be
connected and i'll start with this
because i know a lot of people really
want to know who the boss is now there
are several different options of who the
boss could actually be one option could
be titania herself she's a super
influencer she has super powers and
basically her powers are strength
they're basically the same powers as
she-hulk except she doesn't turn into a
green monster but titania got humiliated
by she-hulk at the end of the first
episode and you know that titania is
going to have some followers she's an
influencer a super influencer so these
could be her lackeys and she could want
she-hulk's blood to make her even more
powerful even more strong and eventually
get back at jennifer walters now this is
an option because we know that titania
is going to be appearing again in the
she-hulk series in fact she's probably
going to be in it a lot in future
episodes and this is an option however i
don't think it is what is actually
happening and let's be honest no offense
to titania i think her character's
awesome but we want somebody a little
bit bigger to be the boss now there is
always the option that the villain red
hood could be the boss in the comics red
hood actually is in charge of the
wrecking crew at one point and we've
just recently learned that he is going
to be the villain of the iron heart
series coming to disney plus we've even
seen photos of him this is a pretty
decent connection so it could be him
however there is a bigger connection and
a bigger villain who i believe is
kingpin and to me this kind of just
makes the most sense we know that
daredevil is going to show up in
she-hulk but we specifically know that
daredevil the new daredevil in his new
yellow suit is going to show up not matt
murdock in court i'm sure we might see
matt murdock in court but everything
that we've seen so far shows us
daredevil so why would daredevil be
working with she-hulk well it's probably
because the wrecking crew is after
she-hulk and they're going to be coming
back daredevil probably knows that they
work for kingpin think about it kingpin
was introduced in hawkeye we know that
he's going to be back in the echo series
even though it seemed like echo killed
him at the end of hawkeye and we know
that daredevil reborn is probably going
to have kingpin as the main villain as
well we also know that daredevil will
also be an echo now in the comics ekko
does shoot kingpin in the face she
actually shoots him in both eyes and he
goes blind however he doesn't die he
eventually gets his sight back and
perhaps that's what he wants she-hulk's
blood for could you imagine a kingpin
who also has hulk properties to him he
would be even more strong than he
already is he would almost be
unstoppable and they actually kind of
set this up in the first episode the
hulk tells jyn now that i've analyzed
your blood he had to get rid of her
blood so nobody else could use it so it
never gets into the wrong hands that was
obviously major foreshadowing i assume
that kingpin probably wants the blood
for its healing property so he can get
his eyesight back but i also think that
in turn this is also going to give him
incredible strength even more than he
already has which is going to set him up
to be a big bad of the mcu but hear me
out he's not going to be a big bad like
kang the conqueror or doom but he's
going to be the street level big bad
kevin feige has already confirmed that
the heroes are basically breaking off
into groups and the three groups that
he's basically confirmed already are the
street level team in which he actually
mentions spider-man and daredevil
together he mentioned the supernatural
side which of course is going to focus
on moon knight and blade and other
characters like that hopefully ghost
rider fingers crossed and of course the
cosmic side and it makes sense that each
kind of group would have their own big
bad and i'm assuming kingpin is going to
be the street levels big bad especially
since kevin feige did say that
spider-man and daredevil were going to
team up it would make sense that they
would team up against kingpin we have
yet to see spider-man in the mcu go up
against kingpin and i think that's
something that a lot of people would
really love to see so there are a ton of
connections here leading me to believe
that kingpin is most likely the boss of
course i could be wrong but it does seem
like there are a lot of connections here
to support this theory now it also does
seem like emil blonsky aka the
abomination is going to be recruited for
the thunderbolts and of course another
option of who the boss could be is
valentina who we've seen pop up a couple
of times in the mcu already recruiting
for a team and we know this team to be
the thunderbolts and perhaps the
wrecking crew was trying to get
she-hulk's blood for thunderbolt ross so
he could become red hulk more on this in
just a bit but first thank you to best
fiends for sponsoring this video i think
we all know how much pressure life can
put on us sometimes and i know it's
really easy to put off having a little
bit of relaxation time and a little bit
of fun but that shouldn't be how it is
and with best fiends and exciting puzzle
adventure game you can have fiendish fun
anywhere anytime best fiends is an
awesome puzzle game that i truly enjoy
because it's not just connecting in
straight lines but you can actually
connect diagonally which is a lot more
fun and you can play at any time because
it's super quick to play and you level
up very very easily in fact the first
time i played it for only a few minutes
i got all the way to level 6. that's
because this game is really easy to just
pick up and get in the zone because it's
super fun one second you're on level one
and then the next thing you know you've
connected enough times to get to level
six and there are literally thousands of
different levels you can play and the
best part is best fiends is free to
download so don't put off your fun time
anymore you've definitely earned it go
to the app store or google play to
download best fiends for free plus earn
even more with five dollars worth of
in-game rewards when you reach level
five that's best fiends without the r
now marvel studios has already announced
the thunderbolts movie officially this
year at sdcc it has a release date of
july 26th of 2024 so it is less than two
years away we've already seen valentina
actually recruit a few people for the
thunderbolts team one of course is u.s
agent john walker the other of course is
yelena bulova who we've already actually
seen working for val if you don't know
who the thunderbolts are they're
basically marvel suicide squad they're a
team of criminals who are working for
the government doing the more dirty work
that the avengers can't be seen doing
plus they probably wouldn't want to do
it anyways so recruitment for the team
has begun and i'm assuming that
abomination is going to be a part of
this team jennifer walters has now
gotten emil blonsky out on parole and
i'm assuming that valentina is going to
show up on that piece of land where he's
going to be going with his seven lovers
and tell him that he basically has to
join the thunderbolts now another part
of the thunderbolts and what could
possibly be going on here in this
episode and overall is red hulk in the
comics thunderbolt ross is red hulk now
recently very very tragically and sadly
william hurt who played thunderbolt ross
has passed away so this is kind of up in
the air right now if they're going to
recast for the character but originally
i think the plan was to have him become
red hulk in the mcu so for the sake of
this theory we're just going to act like
they are going to recast and that
character is still going to be around he
could be the one behind valentina
because after all the thunderbolts team
did come from thunderbolt ross and we
all know how shady the character is so
it makes sense that valentina would be
working for him now i also think the
wrecking crew could be working for him
as well because we know that thunderbolt
ross wants to kind of recreate and
perfect the hulk essentially making and
perfecting a super soldier serum which
we essentially saw in the incredible
hulk but you know we don't talk about
that movie so now that a new hulk is
around and this hulk is seemingly
conscious the entire time not having to
fight an alter ego this would definitely
pique the interest of thunderbolt ross
so he would definitely want the blood of
she-hulk so he could examine it and try
to perfect it so he could be behind the
wrecking crew and maybe he does end up
getting her blood and maybe he uses it
on himself and this is how he could
become red hulk in the mcu now this
episode primarily focuses on two things
one is the trial of the mil blonsky aka
the abomination and the other follows
attorney pugliasee and attorney bukowski
mr bakausi is suing roona who was an elf
from asgard who could shape-shift and
shape-shift it into megan the stallion
and tricked bukowski and he thought he
was actually dating the real megan the
stallion he paid for about 175 000 worth
of things for her including buying her a
passat which should have been a red flag
there which jen even points out that
bukowski is stupid for thinking that
meghan the stallion the super successful
and wealthy woman drives a 40 000 car
now we all know that jen and mr bukowski
used to work together at the da's office
and they didn't really like each other
specifically jyn really does not like
attorney bukowski he is a narcissist and
he is very much delusional and while at
the bar with pugliace they're all kind
of talking crap about him and jyn talks
a lot of things about how delusional he
is and pugliese asked her if she would
be willing to testify under oath in
court of course she says yes because
it's an opportunity to humiliate him but
with jen's help they win the case and
then we see the actual megan the
stallion who is in the courtroom she of
course is there because somebody was
impersonating her this actually sets us
up for the post-credits scene no not the
twerking which is all anybody of course
is talking about right now but the fact
that megan the stallion has now
officially hired jyn walters as her
attorney but of course the twerking does
happen of course they dance to megan the
stallion songs in which she says you are
way more fun than my last attorney jyn
says i will kill for you in which megan
the stallion says dial it back a bit now
the other trial of course is with
jennifer walters defending emil blonsky
and the episode actually starts off with
her being super pissed off at him
because she failed to mention that he
broke out of prison and was fighting in
an underground fighting tournament this
is what we saw in chongqi and the legend
of the ten rings and here's where it
gets kind of interesting and could be a
hint at the thunderbolts actually
happening email tells jin that he was
forced out of the sale by wang and that
it was only one time however we know
from chiang chi that wang and the
abomination have actually practiced
several times wong even mentioned that
they were practicing holding back
abominations punches so they didn't hurt
wang as much so this wasn't just a
one-time thing here wong broke a meal
out several times it looks like so it
looks like emile was kind of lying a bit
now ultimately wang does show up to
jennifer's office and we hear a few
jokes and connections to spider-man no
way home now wong does admit that he did
break mill blonsky out of prison against
his wishes because he required a worthy
opponent as part of his training to
become sorcerer supreme now this makes
you kind of question things because we
know that chiang chi took place after
the blip after the five year gap where
everybody came back but doctor strange
says that he was not the sorcerer
supreme because he was blipped for five
years and wang wasn't implying that wang
became the sorcerer supreme during those
five years however we might have
misinterpreted that perhaps the five
years just gave him the experience that
was required to become the sorcerer's
supreme although that means that during
that five year period there was no
source or supreme this could be a little
bit of a hiccup but it's not that big of
a deal but wong says hey since i'm the
sorcerer supreme and i broke him out i
demand he not be punished but of course
jen is the one defending him not
punishing him and she says that they're
not going to let him out after they see
this wongden makes a reference towards
spiderman no way home he says i know
what you're thinking miss walters and
i'm not erasing everyone's memories not
again in which jyn says that's highly
unethical and wonk says yeah it's also
very messy believe me now this also kind
of seems like a little bit of a hiccup
but i'm sure they'll explain this later
on because wong is not really supposed
to know about the whole memory racing
event because peter parker was supposed
to be erased from everybody's memories
and that may be true but perhaps wong
knows about spider-man it was made clear
at the end of nowhere home that people
still know who spider-man is doctor
strange simply made everybody forget who
peter parker was so wong could know that
doctor strange erased everybody's memory
of who spider-man actually is as in the
person under the mask and that doing
that actually created a lot of
multi-rissal problems that happened
during spider-man knowing home which
wong kind of you know turned his back on
so it's very possible that wong could
have known everything that happened and
the only thing that he simply forgot is
who peter parker is who the identity of
spider-man is but he could remember
everything else because the memory of
spider-man and the events that took
place during spider-man knowing home
were not erased wang then makes another
joke and i'm glad to see this
lighthearted sight of him and he says
okay fine we'll send him to the mirror
dimension jin says no and he says shadow
dimension in which she says no again and
then he says we'll keep that for plan b
in case the trial doesn't work out but
he does agree to show up and testify now
ultimately emil blonsky does convince
everybody that he truly has changed he
has a lot of great witnesses that come
to the stand on his behalf and
eventually wang does show up and says
yep it was me i broke him out emil also
demonstrates that he can turn into the
abomination anytime he wants and turn
back into his normal form but before the
trial ends they look at wang and they
say you do know you have committed a
crime right in which case he just leaves
he's the sorcerer supreme he doesn't
have to answer to anybody except maybe
like some cosmic entities fingers
crossed now all throughout this episode
marvel is pretty clever with using
social media and media in general to
provide humor but also reflect how it
actually is in the real world when
jennifer is walking up to the dodc
prison facility one of the reporters
asks her about the rumor of her being
kicked out of the avengers in which
another reporter hears and instantly
reports on that same rumor stating that
jennifer walters is rumored to have been
kicked out of the avengers that often
happens a lot in real life there's also
a really cool easter egg one time when
she is walking out when a reporter asks
her if this all happened her turning
into she-hulk because of a mafia hit
gone wrong this is actually her origin
story in the comics a person named
nicholas trask had put a hit out on her
because she was defending a client that
he was at odds with so some mafia guy
showed up and shot her this is when
bruce banner took her gave her a blood
transfusion which is how she became
she-hulk so this is a cool little easter
egg here on her origin in the comics
that is now we also see a bunch of
social media posts and videos as well
that i actually find kind of clever
because this is kind of marvel getting
on top and ahead of everything with
people talking about how too many
superheroes are female now in that they
need to make a new superhero instead of
kind of recreating a male superhero
referring to the hulk you can even see
signs of team he hulk and i think this
is pretty clever on marvel's behalf
because they already knew that there
were going to be a bunch of people out
there who don't like she-hulk just
because it's a woman they even have
she-hulk finally go on to news to kind
of control her own narrative in which
the reporter basically asks her kind of
dumb questions and then they say when
they get back they're going to talk
about she-hulk's diet and this is
actually something that kind of happened
in real life and marvel studios when
they would do press conferences or
interviews something that would happened
in the past is that some reporters would
ask the males serious questions but when
they got to the females they would ask
them what their diet was and what they
wear underneath their uniforms so this
is kind of a reflection and a pun on
that and that's she-hulk episode 3. let
me know what you thought about it in the
comments down below and also let me know
what you think about my theories about
kingpin possibly being behind the
wrecking crew don't forget to like the
video and subscribe if you're new to the
channel stay up to date on the mcu for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof